what's up world should play a partner
checking in to China you know me I'm
flamboyant like the fancy bank and I'm
always craving for something more this
is the new seat of the most expensive
this year it's getting to this is the
Guinness World Records most expensive
burger at $295 go you would feel the
same way I feel my wife is trying it is
the closest you can be to listening to a
live session
now they're back over 30,000 to buy them
for six times and then be worth thirty
thousand I'm not mad at that at all
this is the car that cost more than
anything probably cost two or three
these damn car all right so what do you
think it's worth I'm going with 750,000
to me another car so if I cutest suit
would be $50,000 if I Kuna top coat is
about $60,000 I can't wait for my about
coolness suit one of one three bedrooms
six bathrooms
what's the night in this room gonna cost
me well we're friends now so you get a
discount but anybody else that calls me
it's $25,000 and a damn 25,000 this
toothbrush is 3,200 euros which is over
$4,000 5,000 what the [ __ ] dollars
for a toothbrush [ __ ] reading
omnidirectional stereo system for you to
check out as you're seeing it it's
$260,000 okay they waste so much you
can't even still a mile someone's home I
mean that's the bargain it's the most
expensive ice-cream sundae in the world
Tim with the cost of $1000 so in my eyes
those are good numbers you think it's
really birthday if I wanted to give this
jacket made bulletproof what would it
cost at least at a minimum about 15,000
20,000 dollars a little excess
world more luxurious and most expensive
rolling paper made out of 24 karat
edible gold
he's 12-pack of around 50 saw I just so
happened to a brat the world's most
expensive cannabis what you got doc this
is $100 again oh [ __ ] this would be $800
an ounce with the most expensive his
weed is paper I will be doing that [ __ ]
again hundred thousand dollar martini
who the [ __ ] he's gonna pay $100,000 for
martini
this is gonna be our rarest most
expensive Jordan are just shoe in
general what are you looking at what are
you looking for twenty-two like $25 sir
13 when I paid $25,000 for hail naw I
would never ever [ __ ] my money up like
that I got some of the best bull dogs on
the planet right here no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] these are about 10 grand
did you inflate the price because it
became properly tell the truth yeah well
little bit [ __ ] so I really like
dogs when they start being $10,000 these
dogs better not ever die and inside here
it's the most expensive bottled water on
this would experience cost hundred
thousand dollars what are you paying
100,000 for the most expensive water
when you can just drink brain some of
the animals are rather expensive for
example a giraffe you might find
anywhere from 20 to as much as $40,000
$40,000 giraffe not so - [ __ ] me I'm a
psychic medium and a tarot card reader
here in LA for 30 minutes to be 115
which is my lowest it's my starting this
is not my cup of tea I don't see that in
my future this right here is the eminent
ex Armageddon this goes for 10 G's
$10,000 for something that takes four
days and make which only takes one
minute to break here's the thing
I didn't mind taking a trip down that
road foot I don't know if I'm coming
back George and let you add ever the
world's most expensive diamond shoes
ever created he purchased the shoes for
two million dollars
[ __ ] they can they have to come with
socks diamond socks like Michael Jackson
and I'm still not going Bob it on the
side you'll see four hundred handset
white VVS diamonds
this is $48,000 diamonds on shakes I
could see me doing it but I can't drop
that fifth so I'm gonna say accountable
[ __ ] but not so to shoot the west coast
of show this remake of the DeLorean I'm
five hundred the price range I can see
me [ __ ] on my checkbook too so I'm
gonna have to be down with that we have
some crazy things going on this season
please take the time to leave your
comments we'll know what you think about
the most expensive [ __ ] to change
[Music]